okay Conan O'Brien here and I'm in
London and I'm in a car and it's
outfitted with cameras and about to meet
a pretty big star and we're gonna have a
little adventure
Conan this is incredible I can't believe
their cameras here we got this in the
car are we gonna do we're gonna do
carpool karaoke right that's actually
yeah that's James Corden oh yeah oh my
god and the karaoke thing is incredible
it's very gonna do that no no that's his
thing you can't do that that's his thing
so he tell you guys that no don't
what's a coffee we're gonna go get
coffee we're gonna talk about comedy now
that's sad that's seven comedians in
cars getting hurt that's Seinfeld
Seinfeld
I met him yeah I love that guy we're
gonna take that genius that guys genius
I'm gonna do that now that's this thing
we don't do that okay well because if
it's someone else's thing you can't do
that you don't want to do it if it's
really gonna shut this out yeah check
this out okay we're gonna blow up the
internet you want to blow up the
Internet yes ice-blue I'm gonna blow up
the Internet I want to do it love
titties gonna live your world
check this out all right everyone else
has done bells and whistles they get in
the car and they do some good fun okay
it's fun fun yeah but okay
that cool shirt but my fam time yeah cuz
my thing is we take it back to basics
okay six good we play back to basics
let's listen to this yeah we just drive
[Applause]
it's a mind-blower right we're just
we're gonna do guys just drive
let's do it
amazing yeah just drive around yeah okay
look you it's a whole new love it only
let them take me take me there I'll take
ya all right I'm gonna drive I'm a
little I'm have you driven on the Sun
never driven in the United Kingdom
before so this is new to me okay
you didn't feel uh you feel okay about
this I feel pretty good I didn't really
sleep since I got off the plane
ragi okay okay here we go
two guys okay just driving
[Applause]
we're gonna talk any questions you want
to ask me anything I'm trying to
concentrate okay it's tricky yeah yeah
no you're on this side so it's tricky so
let's watch that person up there just
sorry just hold it okay okay guys I got
it just watch this guy right here I know
I'm happy to answer questions if you
have any questions that you know you
came all the way you'd have anything you
want to know be good
I've got american-made coming out saga
movie never really liked you move thank
you it's really good thank you very much
and Nicolson yeah told me you stolen you
know Jack Nicholson diamonds until he
tore down and he yeah he said you know
really don't tell anyone this story but
I I feel like maybe now it's okay if I
could you think I'm sorry again this
roundabouts getting through these
roundabouts is 15 especially on a good
father's side so I get it again if you
could just keep that story for later
okay this remind me later I'll tell you
but yo you could tell it on another show
or something yeah
day visit Tim's is a refinery over there
Battersea its back they're going around
here at the left and get to the Tower
Bridge you know Tom if I wanted a tour
guide and higher ed okay I just hire a
drug addict I didn't imagine this much
traffic and I didn't imagine that over
my brain you don't want to think of
traffic and rain and London in the same
sentence
you know no it's been a while since I
drove even in the states I lost my
license revoked it you do not want to
know why what it's just I'd rather not
get into it okay
okay he was a creep hey let's put it
this way time it was a crazy night was
it yeah it was a crazy night
I took these pills driving the judge was
so mad yeah but was that a red light
right like you can't be on pills and
drive I can't take pills a bride so
you're slightly in the bike lane I just
want to say it's fun having my doors
locked
yeah I I put the child safety lock on
myself no no I have to unlock it it's
the only way you can get to it unless I
hit that button and that door does not
unlock which button is it it's over here
I wouldn't worry about it
yeah sunroof is also locked I got a
question okay let's do it that way
okay okay officer and a gentleman did
you get along with Debra Winger is she
someone who because it the chemistry
felt good but I couldn't tell if that
was just acting or not yeah that was
reaching here with you yeah I mean I met
Debra we got along really well very
talented no you're an officer and
gentleman no I'm in top gun pops your
antenna which I know you're a Top Gun
Richard good other than you did officer
Richard Robbie wouldn't you carry her
it's for the factory cover you're
wearing hood you're wearing removed
you're wearing the you know what you
yeah they're wearing the naval uniform
and you carry her through the factory
yeah I remember that now I remember
thank you you were great I'm very proud
of that performance I love that movie
[Music]
almost over
what's that all right what's it oh you
still for about 45 minutes you're out
hard muscle are you
oh we're just getting started
sure you need it I do not need to go to
the bathroom I'm good
all tanks empty good I wouldn't mind
using bathroom
lightly he wasn't bad when he's a
bathroom you know what essentially why
keep this this looks great
you're gonna have to stop yeah that's
not what I had in mind
it also looks a little used there so
this is gonna work very fast just jeez
that's not what I had in mind this is
not what you had was just no but thank
you gonna thank you very much she came
prepared
[Applause]
hey man dad hey yeah yeah
no not a lot of questions nothing
just driving driving no karaoke
okay yeah please just just okay was a
long call that's good
seriously how long have you been driving
we've been driving about three and a
half hours the halfway point I won't
take it personal if you want to drop me
off right now I am totally fine I could
not live with myself if I gave up now I
would not be able to live with myself
you know okay what is that button there
like that button right there that what
is the one to think if you push that by
the minute but this button yeah what
yeah
[Applause]
okay that was Tom Cruise movies
american-made I think that went very
well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
you